there is a new report
that Donald Trump is spending uh days
workshopping nicknames for Ron DeSantis
now I have to tell you this is not a
story about oh it's another Trump rumor
this is genuinely a smart thing to do
this with where the Republican party is
coming up with the best possible
nickname with which to brand and
stigmatize Ron DeSantis
is a good use of time for Trump a lot of
the things Trump spends time on are
completely useless but this makes sense
there's an article in the hill Trump
spends days workshopping nicknames for
DeSantis former president Trump has made
developing nicknames for his Republican
rival and potential presidential
opponent Ron DeSantis a priority as his
team works on his 2024 campaign
according to a new Bloomberg report
has floated Ron dishonest Ron The
Establishment and Tiny d as monikers for
the Florida governor but appears to
favor Ron de sanctimonius Trump coined
to sanctimonious ahead of the midterm
elections and shortly before launching
his own presidential bid so let's talk
about this
um
Trump is terrible at a ton of things as
I said earlier he is good at making fun
of people that's the reality he's good
at nicknaming people he's good at
stigmatizing people and when you are
potentially going to be fighting someone
as uncharismatic and seemingly unable to
handle your style of attack as Ron
DeSantis one of the best things you can
do is nickname him with something that
will really titillate and scintillate
and hope that he is unable to respond in
kind now the problem with
disanctimonious is I don't think a lot
of Republican voters necessarily know
what it means
and of course it is actually accurate
which is when your sanctimonious you
make a show out of being or appearing
morally Superior to others
Ron DeSantis does do that
you need only look at his State of the
State address from yesterday that he
gave in Florida uh to confirm that but I
don't know that a lot of Republican
voters necessarily know what
sanctimonious means so tiny D is pretty
interesting and there's also this uh
high heels story I don't know this is so
insane that this is where the Republican
party is but Ron DeSantis for a while
has been wearing it's it's I it's it's I
laugh because it's crazy that this is
where we are in American politics
DeSantis has been wearing high-heeled
cowboy boots for a while but now there
is a new suspicion that he's also
wearing lifts inside the boot which by
the way Trump is also suspected of
wearing don't think the sanctimonious is
the only guy doing this so uh Ron
DeSantis officially is only five nine
um but there are images of him looking
as tall as people who are known to be
over six feet tall so of course the idea
would be DeSantis puts a lift inside the
boot and then wears a high heel and then
he looks 6-1 and people think he's
taller than he actually is all of this
stuff really matters
tall candidates tend to do better now do
they tend to do better because they're
tall well that's a different question uh
we we'd have to look at that in a
different way but it wouldn't surprise
me if Trump focused in on some kind of
nickname that related to DeSantis
actually being short ER I mean listen
I'm five nine also five seven five five
nine five nine at least that's what my
license says let's put it that way
um and then you know sort of being
desperate to be six feet tall and
wearing high heels and cowboy boots I
don't know where it's going but it
wouldn't surprise me that it goes in
that uh in in that direction again I
believe that DeSantis is 100 worse than
Trump Adam Schiff had a different
feeling yesterday which was that Trump
really is the danger I think Trump's
incompetence actually makes him less
dangerous and that he's less able to
accomplish things DeSantis is completely
uncharismatic completely uninspiring as
a speaker but he would uh pose a real
threat of getting some really dangerous
stuff done so if I had to pick I think I
actually do think
the Democratic candidate is better off
facing Trump
and the risk of a trump presidency is
lower than that of a DeSantis presidency
continuing to take opinions from you in
the audience about that question